[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon
elle ne pas notamment tant de temps en
commentant notamment quand même comment
peut-on ne pas mon temps me tomtom en
commentant montant m'enfin quand même
pas mon père ne comprend pas elle même à
me demander comment ne pas me
[Musique]
en attendant si vous le voulez bien
antenne 2 commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
concorde devant ses juges américains
verdict dans un mois dell républicains
pour la course à la maison blanche ford
en baisse reagan en hausse 17 jours
d'absentéisme par an et par salarié
est ce une cause du déficit de la
sécurité sociale
bilan provisoire de l'ouragan venus du
nord plus de 50 morts des villages
engloutis plusieurs milliards de dégâts
bonsoir ce n'est qu'une petite phrase
sur concorde mais elle a des tonnes de
poussée
ce sont les militaires du nacre avis qui
souvent la vie bien plus jolie
dans les rets nous gagner sans merogis
notoires dont le son sans oublier avec
m
les sens du goût
oc
on voit des heures sous le béton
c'est la magie d'ailleurs chanson les
lacanau
[Musique]
bonjour cette émission spéciale cuisine
que nous vous proposons aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et
on ne pas ne tendent pas ne pas manquer
mais quand même pas mon temps à ça ne
tombe en panne de temps mais quand même
pas mal quand même en même temps elle
était même à ne pas manquer
[Musique]
coût
et oui récré a2 c'est votre émission
tous les jours pendant les vacances je
ne vais pas être seul pour vous la
présenter rassurez vous je suis en
compagnie d'un goût dit vous dis
qu'est-ce que ce qu'elle vous dis goody
c'est un héros gentil d'un western c'est
ça ça bah oui c'est mon goût du goût dit
de vous dit vous dit tu as deux grandes
jambes
oui embarqués tels bonne tête quand même
on peut bien bronzés les belles dents
blanches un regard pétillant et plein de
tendresse et d'intelligence parfois non
ça joue la musique paraît-il qui serais
tu tires beaucoup plus vite que toi je
suis le plus fort au marché en amour
c'est gérard hier ça vous tient des
situations les plus périlleuses six ans
dorothée tué la fille du soleil
je vais t'emmener dans ma diligence nous
allons nous enfuir loin des indiens way
le bétail a passé la frontière voilà ça
te fous de ma tombe en arrière et bien
écoute match à dorothée moi aussi je
suis très content d'être à récré a2 et
je ne suis pas venu comme ça j'ai
apporté des petites chansons pour toi
l'europe et oui les petites chansons
seulement comme je ne savais pas quel
genre de chanson tu aimais alors j'en ai
composé trois petits trois petites
différentes
une ballade rock and roll 1 une petite
berceuse qui est prêt puis coûtent à la
suva
et tu oses andrieu
et d'un livre d'histoire un jour s'est
envolé corps
elle connaît des secrets lutteurs sont
ses amis
lt chanter les joueurs
[Musique]
je veux être ton ami
raconte
des histoires de
il a été tué comme mon ami
pour m'apprendre à chanter comme un
grand cas d'à alors on m'a dit aussi
dorothée que tu aimais danse et que tu
dansais très bien et que tu dansais
aussi je crois que molle alors je lui
peut chanter le taux voté voir comment
dorothée avec moi je dansais dorothée
avec toiles de gens ne voulaient pas
bien
[Musique]
selon lui
dans l'année
lentement le temps
[Musique]
par là
la bouche de beaucoup plus calme
maintenant monsieur aussi tu veux bien
une petite berceuse
on va je voudrais la panthère tu veux la
panthère c'est la première rose mais
nettoyer dans un encrier tient alors la
petite berceuse ça fait de dorothée lors
sur mon oreiller je viendrai se
réveiller
d'or nord dorothée dans la nuit de l'été
des oiseaux ont chanté
rêve rêves de beauté
au dessin animé on histoires de fées
rêve rêves
dans
laissez-moi la famille
dans tes yeux ont brillé là
une
pu camper
aucun domaine
un baby
moi par les mêmes
quand les tranquilles quand on est bien
on arrive on peut discuter au livre ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais au fait de la vie si tous kankan
est astucieux bellemène est la plus
connue
le plus sérieux à jouer c'est devenu un
ami on la tient la note 10
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il va souayah d'or
là
la fin
[Musique]
là
m
la blague à
[Musique]
à mort
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
à
quatre et dix dollars du pétrole
[Musique]
tu ne connais pas
tu y es
le revolver et on y dort
[Musique]
là tu te rends compte
passé
[Musique]
la main
lui qui n'a pas compris
à
aujourd'hui les perdre la vie
[Musique]
non
l'univers nettoyage
[Musique]
laurie la loi
à
ma
lui qui n'a pas
là
j'aurais dû perdre la vie au
à
ton univers impitoyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
tu qu'il est posé dans l'attentât
[Musique]
on est bien
c'est la peine
on s'amuse en chantant
méchant c'est ça les visiteurs du
mercredi
nle
la codi
w
bonjour j'espère on s'est tous en pleine
forme à 2h spéciale 6 10 ans avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
pas
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
pas
[Musique]
oh
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
oui
oh
c
bonsoir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir merci merci de cet accueil
chaleureux et pardon pour cette semaine
de retard c'est la première de champs
elysées nous nous retrouverons tous les
samedis à 20h30 sur antenne 2 pendant 70
minutes environ divertissante après une
semaine difficile de vous méritez aussi
de vous divertir cette émission sa
modeste ambition est de vous faire
oublier vos soucis en vous faisant
découvrir des visages nouveaux qui
seront associés à des locomotives je
voudrais remercier tous ceux qui sont
venus assister à notre émission dans les
plus beaux jardins du monde c'est un
journaliste qui l'a écrit ce matin les
jardins des champs elysées là où marcel
proust en 1880 est menée à jouer au
cerceau et cet espace c'est très célèbre
dans le monde entier déjà à l'espace
cardin
c'est là où nous nous retrouverons les
missions et public il n'y a pas beaucoup
de place pas nous en vouloir c'est pas
baltard mais si vous êtes patient quand
l'émission et eve 2 mai vers si vous
nous écrivez dès maintenant j'espère que
vous recevrez vos places je remercie la
presse de province la presse parisienne
qui est là je le ferai plus longuement
tout à l'heure et j'aimerais pour
commencer que vos applaudissements aille
à ceux qui ont beaucoup travaillé avec
nous ils sont un petit peu tremblant ce
soir car transformer un petit théâtre
ensuite des autres télévisions savait
pas évident ce sont tous les techniciens
de la sfp
[Applaudissements]
merci je vais pas tous les citer mais je
vais citer le réalisateur jacques brialy
je vais citer francis remballe
décorateur charles higuéro dalta
monsieur connaissait pas c'est lucas
équipe et tout ça avec la lumière
il ya notre ami martial tuerie qui est
le directeur de la photo il un rôle
capital à jouer ce soir et je voudrais
bien sûr remercié accueillir dans cette
salle nos patrons notre président
directeur général pierre des groupes est
représentée par joseph pasteur est
également présente ce jacques nakache il
faut toujours applaudir les patrons et
bill émission
couleurs les bons offices
[Musique]
mon but
on va
[Musique]
oh
bonjour à tous nos amis mais aussi
bonjour à ce qui peut être aujourd'hui
l'académie des neuf avec capeline riches
arlette thomas michel lève il fait son
entrée dans l'académie claude lemesle à
ses côtés alice dona ou qu'elle est
belle daniel faure et laurence art les
académies des 10 donc mérette pradier et
gadget à monter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour a tous poussé moi aujourd'hui
vous retrouverez ces chouettes l'école
[Musique]
m